I asked our own Andy Richter to research
the brexit break it down for us how'd it
go Andy I think it went pretty great
gone and I learned a lot and I think our
viewers will too
Great Britain is comprised of three
countries England Scotland and Wales
last week millions of citizens went to
the polls to vote on the brexit the word
brexit is a combination of the words
British and exit kind of like Brangelina
and Blitzer bash because to leave the
European Union was spearheaded by Boris
Johnson the offspring of Donald Trump
and a yellow Labrador national he said
leaving the EU could save the Brits 13
billion euros a year to give you an idea
of how much 13 billion is that's 1
billion more than 12 billion and it's 5
billion more than 8 billion really blows
your mind but how does the monarchy feel
about the breaks I tried calling the
Queen but she is too busy rehearsing for
the upcoming vh1 hip-up honors the vh1
hip-hop honors pays tribute to classic
hip-hop artists like Big Daddy Kane and
kool Moe Dee
anyway the Brits voted to win which
caused a panicked sell-off of stocks
worldwide and you know what that means
pictures of men touching their face
[Applause]
by leaving they've declared their
independence from the rest of Europe a
melting pot of tiny cars do sex on
vespers underaged smokers Christoph
bolts castle people these idiots
Dracula's topless bathers and dangling
meats there you have it
[Applause]
the live thanks a lot
you